Ciao Gu ciao ospite, abito in condominio,
il tipo che sta sopra di me è il
classico vicino rumoroso, quarantenne
scapolo divorziato, bello e impossibile
che ogni tanto si porta a casa qualche
ragazza, si fa sentire diciamo, ma la sua
particolarità è che è appassionato di
aviazione. Un giorno ha deciso di
atterrare sul tetto di casa con un elicottero
Che vuol dire? Cioè un giorno sentiva tipo "tutum tutum"
"Oh si meraviglioso" ogni volta capito
in una lingua diversa, e un giorno "tototototo" quasi
quasi che tu dici...ci sta prorpio dando dentro! (Enrico)
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di Vita
Buttata, il tema della puntata di oggi è "Vicini di casa"
Per un tema così importante ho deciso di fare un qualcosa
di nuovo. Io solitamente all'interno degli studios
de casa mia ospito sempre parenti, amici
o comunque persone che conosco. Oggi
invece ho pensato di ospitare
all'interno del mio canale una ragazza
che ho incrociato un po' di volte, con la
quale ci siamo sempre così sorrisi
presentati al volo, mi ricordo ancora che
la prima cosa che mi ha detto è  "Ma perché stai a
venì qua?". E quindi mi è stata subito molto
simpatica e sto parlando della mia
vicina di casa Emanuela. Ciao ciao a
tutti. Oh eccoti qui. Possiamo dire che
noi è la prima volta che...effettiva...
effettiva, diciamo ci conosciamo e subito
lei è rimasta delusa particolarmente e
anch'io devo dire. Ah perfetto! Sono abbastanza
curioso di sapere...capito? Perché tu sei
una brava, vai tipo alle assemblee
com'è che si chiamano? Le riunioni? Sisi le assemblee condominiali. Esatto, tu ci vai? Ci sono andata quella
volta che forse ho sgamato qualcosa che Guglielmo...
Si vabbè ne parleremo più avanti
No io non ci vado mai perché non non ce... la
mia vita è già difficile cioè....Capisco
Ma ci si scanna alle assemblee
di condominio? E' un condominio molto
tranquillo in realtà. Potrebbe succedere
qualcosa se vieni tu. Hai visto che
super tecnica ha? Perfetta! Va bene? No perché guarda che io so imbarazzata regà, cioè mo per voi magari è la
normalità, ma per me...Non so se guardà lì
se guadar te. Come ti pare. No questo e per
tranquillizzarti, te ne rendi conto subito
se uno ha i tempi o no. Tu ce li hai, quindi
vai tranquilla. Stai segnando? Hai i tempi, tipo il
tempo di andartene... Guarda ti posso chiedere un
fazzoletto? Certo (Gianmarco). Lo hai chiesto poi con giusto tempo (Enrico)
Era perfetto! Aspetta (Gianmarco). Sei fuori tempo eh... Grazie. Ok, ti potrai soffiare il naso o tamponare
col Natale. Allora vai. Vi dico solo che al piano di sopra al mio c'è un uomo che ha come animale
domestico una gallina e che ogni giorno la
porta a spasso nel cortile di casa mia
che chiama ripetutamente "Giuditta Giuditta", cioè ha una gallina che si chiama Giuditta. Ma in più questa
gallina gli dà ascolto, ogni volta che
lui la chiama lei lo segue. Fantastico!
Hai capito la fortuna che ha però? Il suo animale
domestico in realtà frutta. Si dice bucio di c**o
e pensa quello della gallina...Che tempo! Se mi devi dare delle dritte dammele
Nono tu non hai bisogno di dritte.
No mo lo stai a dì...Nono davvero, te lo dico
tranquillamente. Ha i tempi quindi...ho già
guadagnato. E fu così che rimase zitta...per tutto il tempo
Una mattina sono stato svegliato non dalla
solita sveglia ma bensì da un toro i*******o
nero che muggiva come un matto che si
era rifugiato nel mio giardino, solo che nel mio giardino c'era
anche il mio vicino di casa. Probabilmente
piantava pomodori o qualcosa, quello sta sempre a
piantar qualcosa. Questo signore qua il
vicino di casa parla al toro facendogli
"Ciao ciao, e tu chi sei? Ma tu chi sei? Ciao, cosa ci fai qui? Ciao". Poco
dopo arriva ovviamente il padrone di
questo toro, lo riesce a riacchiappare e
sento il mio vicino di casa che tra sé e
sé dice "Oh ma che bel manzo! Ohohohoh" e rinizia a
scavare. Pensavo si fosse poi svegliato
lui sudato da un sogno. Oddio, è tutto
finto! Non sto comprendendo, col vicino
che nel suo giardino piantava forse
pomodori e parla a un toro come se fosse
un coniglietto. Piantava tori (Enrico)
E mi sembra un po' come il nostro vicino...quello li? Si, che pianta da una vita. Da quando è entrato ha messo
terra ovunque, piante ovunque... e non cresce
niente...niente. E' un po' un Dexter Morgan della serie
serial killer. E ha questa roba tipo avvitata... dove le
piante dovrebbero girare intorno...non gira un c***o.
Con le bustone nere ogni tanto esce
Cadaveri giustamente...da killer.
Guarda che potrebbe essere un killer, non cresce
niente. Ma i cadaveri teoricamente fanno da concime, quindi non è un serial killer (Enrico)
Hai fatto un'affermazione sgradevole... Eh ma è vera! (Enrico)...quindi non è un assassino?
No. E' un assassino che non ha un buon
pollice verde. Allora "Camuffa la voce
anche perché sembra che sto per morire".
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, se si tratta di
vicini penso di poter dire che il mio vicino probabilmente è un serial killer. Ha lo sguardo da pazzo, tratta male sia
i suoi cani che i vicini, spacca specchietti di macchine che gli parcheggiano davanti casa oppure squarta
ruote di macchine varie. E è tutto vero. Quando passi davanti alla sua casa senti una puzza di
carogna incredibile. E' un pazzo, cioè io spero di non incontrarlo mai! Spero che si trasferisca al più presto
Ciao Gu. Vattene tu prima di lui! Ma che vuol dire? Ma che uomo? Puzza di
carogna, spacca gli specchietti,
squarcia le gomme della macchina
Ti accorgi della sua presenza tramite la musica di suspense (Enrico)
Aspetta che c'è un altro pezzo. Ah in tutto ciò ho dimenticato la parte più interessante che prevede
l'avvelenare tutti i gatti del circondario per poi dare la colpa ad altri vicini di casa
Piazzare telecamere che riescano a
filmare quello che succede nelle case altrui
Allora...Gravissimo! Si, tesoro mio, ma una
bella bella denuncia? Da buttarlo proprio
fuori subito da lì...e metterlo
all'interno di una nuova casa che si
chiama carcere, con delle sbarre...con la puzza di carogna...con la puzza di carogna, la sua
Voi vi ricordate quel micettino che aveva
c****o quella singola volta? Da allora ha dato
il via e quindi sul mio box auto adesso
c'è sopra scritto "Autogrill". E' da un po' che non scendo
Ho il terrore, io devo
andare con una pala, un sacco nero e
dare al vicino concimatore un po' di m***a.
Togliamoci questo dente, cosa è successo?
L'ho contattata tramite Instagram,
chiedendo a mio cugino di contattarla
tramite una sua amica che conosceva
un'altra sua amica che al mercato mio
padre comprò e quindi c'è stata tutta
questa catena qua. Perché mio cugino
la conosceva? Perché la sua amica della
sua amica che al mercato mio padre comprò
un giorno andò da lui e disse "Oh ma te sei il
cugino di Guglielmo? Calcola che io conosco
una ragazza e dice che non va mai alle
assemblee e che tipo vogliono buttare la
roba che il suo ex ha lasciato in casa...nel sottoscala...nel sottoscala
Ragazzi, io subito avrei lasciato bruciare tutti quegli
oggetti. Prima che quello è venuto...Fra l'altro noi
complici (Enrico)...voi complici. Tra parantesi
non so se lo vedi lì. Ancora una parte
restante. Suo che ha detto "E' tuo". Figurati se questo...
No possiamo farlo vedere? Lì è rimasto. Mo magari è
tipo l'appendiabiti di mezza Italia. Sicuramente. Questo qui un appendiabiti che lui mi
ha lasciato dicendomi che era mio.
Soprattutto la cosa positiva è che lui
comunque...grazie Enrico...
lui comunque si è portato i nove bustoni
che sapevano di piscio di gatto.
Ah l'importante è quello. Mi dispiace per il
condominio. Ma erano molto alterati? No ma
teoricamente si stava ipotizzando che
cosa fare di quella roba che stava nel sottoscala. E subito sono stato tanato vero io? Si. Ma quindi io ho la
nomea di quello che fa un po'...no, nonono...sei certa? Sono certa. Sono io che ti ho difeso. Davvero? Non si
fa tra vicini? Giusto, il problema è che anche gli altri erano miei vicini. Però tu ti rendi conto che è
un miracolo che a me ancora non mi hanno
fatto saltare. Ma l'ho comprata io
questa casa. Esatto. Quindi io posso essere il
vicino antipatico e odioso. Forse tu non hai riparato
il citofono proprio per (Enrico)...
per evitare. In realtà sto per murare la porta. Io mi
lancerò col deltaplano dal balcone. Ma
non si è mai sentito quando ho fatto il
karaoke? Ah per fortuna! Ne so altre di questo
condominio ma non le posso dire. Diciamo
che sono nel reparto Hot. Hot si si sente
Quanti posti ha un letto matrimoniale?
Quanto uno ne vuole. Esatto
esatto, esattamente. Chiarissimo! Ciao Gu buongiorno. Allora, io ho il bagno comunicante con il salotto
di questa persona, quindi ero al bagno
intenta a espletare le mie funzioni
giornaliere, sento ansimare fortemente dall'altro lato della stanza, alché
avvicino l'orecchio perché comunque
volevo ascoltare cose stesse succedendo
e sentivo la padrona di casa dire
queste esatte parole
Addirittura stiamo per avere le esatte
parole? E' un audio importante ragazzi!
Si amore di mamma continua così, si amore,
bel patatone di mamma, oh si amore mi fai
impazzire e continuando così per almeno
mezz'ora. La cosa diciamo che tu penserai
è "Oh mio Dio se la sto facendo con il
figlio", se non ancora peggio. Aveva due
cani e ha cominciato a dire che bel p*****o, stava s********* ** p******
del suo cane. No non ci credo. No no no no Ciao Gu buona giornata. No che buona giornata, ce l'ha distrutta
la giornata. No no no no nonononononono...Lei è stata mezz'ora con l'orecchio appiccicato al muro (Enrico)
Era la sua testa che usciva dal muro.
Che schifo, no vabbè, non sarà così! Da paura!
Per fortuna non ho una buona memoria, per
fortuna lo dimenticherò fra poche ore
Ciao Gi sono qui con le mie coinquiline...Ciao...per
raccontarti che ormai da tre anni
abbiamo un'amabile vicina del piano di
sotto che oltre ad appendere bambole
nude a testa in giù dal balcone, ad avere
una targhetta sulla porta con scritto
"Welcome to Hell" e gli angioletti impiccati e
inseguirci con il palo della scopa
ululando su sottofondo Profondo rosso,
per dimostrarci il suo amore ci lascia
anche questi bigliettini sul portone del
condominio
Ora ti alleghiamo il biglietto. Però
almeno scrive? Nono almeno? Voglio capire
almeno. Almeno cioè un messaggio amoroso
scritto. Certo! Ladri tutti voi studenti
speriamo vi venga la m*******a
come siete voi, auguri s*****i pulitevi il c**o auguri
Tutto l'amore che ha. A te è stata simpatica?
Starebbe  (Gianmarco). Perchè non sei uno
studioso (Enrico). Si è vero non sei uno studioso
O se hai una testa di cavallo da portarle per
poter praticare dei riti pagani
Questa mia ex vicina di casa era vedova da parecchi
anni. Lei professava fuori di casa la
castità, la purezza di consumare dopo il
matrimonio ma invece dentro casa professava l'arte
del trombamico diciamo. Ogni tot periodo
c'era una persona diversa che faceva con
lei...dai dillo non essere in imbarazzo...e diciamo che lei
trombava di brutto, tantissimo, e a volte faceva cose
con più persone o cose singole
La cosa inquietante è che lei aveva 67 anni
e trombava di più di quanto trombo io adesso. Mamma
mia ragazzi. Clamorosa! Ma aspetta qui abbiamo altri sei secondi
comunque. E nulla con questi messaggi poi
volevo semplicemente dirle "Complimenti"
Complimenti. Complimenti signora. I miei
complimenti. Per la coerenza gli regge
proprio com'è che si dice la tromba....la pompa...la s****a (Enrico)
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, e che c***o ridi però, per annullare l'operazione. Non ci sei riuscita. Ciao Gu scusa per prima
ma non siamo capaci a fare gli audio su Facebook,...esatto
comunque ti vogliamo mandare una
testimonianza della nostra vecchia vicina
di casa un po' strana. Capirete dal prossimo audio che vi manderemo. Potrebbero mettere la
pubblicità tra una cosa e l'altra e io l'aspetterei per vederla
*urla disumane*
Satana in persona non so. E lei mentre lo diceva
stava sul soffitto...a testa in giù. Era un po' altreata
Un po'....era un po' alterata...*urla disumane*... ti sei resa conto...che stavo così. E' difficilissimo...stare dritti
Adesso guarda guarda come so magra adesso. Vai vai così ti voglio. Perfetto sentiamo l'audio così
Tipo Barbara D'Urso. Posso? Ciao Gu, io ti voglio
raccontare del mio ex vicino di casa che
era un pazzo furioso da galera. Lui
praticamente odiava profondamente i miei
cani, tant'è che ogni volta che tornava
dal lavoro scendeva dalla macchina, si
girava verso il mio giardino e gli urlava
fate schifo pezzi di m***a, teste di c***o, cose così.
Urlava queste cose ogni giorno ai miei
cani ma il punto massimo lo ha toccato
una notte quando si è messo davanti al
cancello di casa mia col suo
telefonino a riprendere i miei cani che
abbaiavano urlandogli "Fate schifo pezzi di m***a"
e cose così. Io non ho mai capito perché
anche perché aveva anche lui un cane. Non
lo so insomma è inutile direi che lo
abbiamo denunciato alla polizia. Ohh...
denuncia! Ohhh denuncia, quella cosa inizia
con la d e non finisce con ado ma enuncia.
Così si fa ragazzi, quando ci sono
veramente dei problemi seri...si prende la
posizione...si invece che Vita Buttata la
polizia. Pezzi di fango, a dei cani. Che problema...o
vedeva in loro qualcun altro. Vallo a
capire! Dovremmo chiedergli i nomi dei cani quali
erano. Pezzi e M***a...Siamo finalmente arrivati
alla fine di questo strazio, ci siamo resi
conto che l'italia è un paese pieno...di pazzi.
Si, di persone...disagiate proprio...si, e la maggior
parte di quelle persone abitano
anche all'interno di questa dimora
Si il nostro condominio ecco, ma allo stesso tempo posso dire, siamo fin troppo
fortunati. Direi di si. Io farò vedere
quando verrò a un'assemblea questo video
in questo modo ci cacceranno. Esatto. E' finita per tutti e due
Che dire ringrazio tutti quanti voi che
avete seguito questo, questo video e
ringrazio soprattutto te Emanuela per la super disponibilità. Grazie. No sei stata
super super gentile. Ormai caffè, ce l'hai il
sale? Perfetto. Capito? Quelle cose tipo
Approvata! Ti aspettiamo. Stessa cosa per me
Perfetto. Tanto non c'ho un c***o, capito? Se ti serve qualcosa. Lo vedo lo vedo. Come sempre io vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale. Se non volete
perdere nessun video attivate anche la
notifica e che dire ci vediamo la prossima
settimana con un altro video
Ciao ciao. Ciao